lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en todas las diferentes maneras
en las que podemos representar datos y
lo que yo tengo aquí es una lista del
puntaje que obtuvieron algunas alumnas
en su último examen entonces tenemos que
andrea obtuvo 90
tania 95 mayra 100 melissa 100 y lis
obtuvo 80 en su examen ahora esta fue
una manera de mostrar datos pero
recuerda que los datos son simplemente
un registro de información puede ser
numérico como en este caso o puede ser
de cosas como que tanto les gustó el
examen y eso puedes registrar como me
gustó me gustó poco o no me gustó y
también pudieron utilizar una escala del
0 al 5 en la cual aunque tendríamos
números estos valores estarían midiendo
la opinión de las personas pero en este
caso en este caso tenemos números que
están midiendo los puntajes que
obtuvieron las alumnas en el examen
empecemos a ver cuáles serían diferentes
formas de representar datos una manera
sería formar una tabla entonces vamos a
formar una tabla donde pongo una columna
de nombres y la columna de puntajes ahí
está entonces voy a formar las columnas
tenemos la columna de los nombres y la
columna de los puntajes en este caso
esos nombres corresponden a las alumnas
y los puntajes al puntaje que obtuvieron
en su examen y ahí está la tabla y esta
sería una manera muy común de
representar datos de hecho se puede
pensar en una tabla como ésta como la
manera tradicional de representar datos
pero también hay otras formas por
ejemplo una gráfica de barras o
histograma entonces voy a dibujar aquí
una gráfica de barras pongo los ejes
tenemos el eje vertical el eje
horizontal el eje vertical corresponde
al puntaje que obtuvieron en su examen y
el horizontal corresponde a los nombres
de las alumnas y en el eje vertical
pongo rayas que representen los puntajes
entonces tenemos 10 20 30 40 50 60 70 80
90 y 100 así que el puntaje 100 sería
este de arriba este representa el
puntaje 100 y este representa el puntaje
50 muy bien ahora veamos andrea andrew
obtuvo 90 podemos ver en la tabla que
andrea escribo su nombre
ella obtuvo 90 en su examen así que voy
a dibujar una barra
que llegue hasta el 90 entonces tenemos
que andrea obtuvo 90 dibujó una barra
que llega hasta el 90 ahí está ahora
tania según la tabla ella obtuvo 95
entre el 90 y el 100 por ahí más o menos
voy a dibujar una barra que llega hasta
el 95 es el puntaje que obtuvo tá nea
mayra obtuvo 100 entonces ella llega
hasta el tope aquí está el 100 la línea
que representa el 100
entonces dibujo una barra que llega
hasta el 100 para representar el puntaje
de mayra melissa obtuvo 100 entonces
melissa ella también obtuvo 100
ahí está la barra que representa el
puntaje de melissa y lis obtuvo 80
80 que sería guiándonos más o menos del
50 50 60 70 80 ahí está entonces la
barra de él y llega hasta el número 80
que sería el puntaje que ella obtuvo y
esta sería otra forma visual de
representar datos es otra manera pero
observa que esta gráfica de barras
contiene exactamente la misma
información que la tabla en ambas formas
de representar datos tú puedes buscar el
nombre del alumno y ver qué puntaje
obtuvo entonces por ejemplo vemos que
andrea según la tabla ella obtuvo 90 y
también en la gráfica de barras vemos
que andrea obtuvo 90
tania obtuvo 95 según la tabla y también
vemos que en la gráfica de barras dane
obtuvo 95
mayra ella obtuvo
tanto en la gráfica de barras como en la
tabla ahí está contienen exactamente la
misma información
melissa obtuvo también 100 ahí lo
podemos ver y liz obtuvo 80 list obtuvo
80 contiene la misma información a ambas
formas de representar los datos
contienen exactamente la misma
información y bueno ahí ya tenemos la
gráfica de barras y tenemos tenemos una
tabla pero hay más maneras en las que
podemos registrar esta información por
ejemplo podríamos excluir los nombres si
no incluimos los nombres tendríamos
menos información solamente tendríamos
una lista de los cinco puntajes que se
obtuvieron se obtuvo un puntaje de 90 se
obtuvo un puntaje de 95 se obtuvo un
puntaje de 100
un puntaje de 100 otro puntaje de 100
y un puntaje de 80 y si está afuera toda
la información que se te da puedes ver
que tienes menos información que en la
gráfica de barras o en la tabla en la
tabla y en la gráfica de barras no
solamente conocemos los puntajes sino
también quien obtuvo qué puntaje tenemos
los nombres así que bueno aquí es menos
información la tabla y la gráfica de
barras contienen más información
contienen también los nombres y hay más
maneras de representar datos por ejemplo
puedes representar datos fijándote en la
frecuencia de los puntajes así que voy a
dibujar aquí una
una gráfica de frecuencia en lugar de
escribir los nombres voy a escribir
solamente los puntajes que se obtuvieron
podemos iniciar en 80 85 90 95 y 100
entonces ahí tenemos en el eje
horizontal los puntajes que obtuvieron
las alumnas en su examen así que
registremos la frecuencia de los
puntajes cuántas veces tenemos el
puntaje 80 una vez listo obtuvo 80
cuantas veces tenemos el puntaje 85
ninguna vez 90
tenemos el puntaje de 90 una vez
entonces voy a colocar aquí un punto
el puntaje de 95 vemos que tanja obtuvo
el puntaje de 95 así que lo tenemos una
vez y tenemos que mayra obtuvo 100 y
melissa también obtuvo 100 así que en el
puntaje 100 tenemos una frecuencia de 22
veces se obtuvo el puntaje 100 esta es
otra manera de representar registro de
datos y al eje vertical lo podemos ver
como el número de veces que se obtuvo un
puntaje es decir la frecuencia de los
puntajes y este tipo de registro de
datos tienen la misma información que la
lista de puntajes y ahora ya con todos
estos datos organizados podemos comenzar
a hacer preguntas interesantes como por
ejemplo podríamos preguntarnos cuál es
el rango de los datos que tenemos cuál
es el rango de los datos que tenemos
donde rango es la extensión entre el
punto más alto y el punto más bajo
entonces lo voy a escribir aquí el rango
es la diferencia que hay
el valor máximo y el valor mínimo es la
diferencia entre el valor máximo y el
valor mínimo eso es el rango en este
caso tenemos que el valor máximo es el
100 y el valor mínimo es el 80 aquí
vemos el valor máximo es el 100 y el
valor mínimo es el 80 entonces vamos a
restar 100 y 80 tenemos el valor máximo
100 menos el valor mínimo 80 eso es
igual a 20 ahora también podríamos
preguntarnos por ejemplo cuántas
personas obtuvieron un puntaje menor a
100 cuántas personas obtuvieron un
puntaje menor a 100 son preguntas
interesantes y que se pueden contestar
con cualquiera de estas diferentes
representaciones de datos entonces
veamos cuántas personas obtuvieron un
puntaje menor a 100 en la tabla vemos
puntajes menor a 100 este este esto es
no
así que 3 en la gráfica de barras
puntajes menores a 100 vemos este
este esto es no y este así que otra vez
3 aquí también podemos ver
este puntaje es menor a 100 este y este
otra vez tres y
en la gráfica de frecuencia vemos este
este y este así que en cualquiera de las
representaciones vemos que la respuesta
es 33 personas que obtuvieron un puntaje
menor a 100 también podríamos
preguntarnos por ejemplo cuál fue el
puntaje más frecuente esa es una
pregunta interesante entonces cuál fue
el puntaje más frecuente veamos el más
frecuente en la tabla observamos el
puntaje 90 sólo una vez el 95 también
sólo una vez dos veces el cien y sólo
una vez el 80 entonces el puntaje más
frecuente fue el 100 también en la
gráfica de barras podemos observar que
el puntaje 90 sólo sale una vez el 95
sólo una vez pero el 100 sale dos veces
tenemos el puntaje dos veces y el 80
sólo una vez en la lista de puntajes
también observamos dos veces el 100 y
los demás sólo una vez pero en la
de frecuencia es donde más claro se ve
que el dato más frecuente es el 100 el
100 aquí tiene dos puntos entonces
puedes verlo en la gráfica de frecuencia
que el puntaje que tiene más puntos es
el 100 así que ese es el más frecuente
pero bueno en fin todo esto que te
mostré fue una manera muy general en la
que podemos ver distintas formas de
representar datos todas estas formas son
diferentes pero los datos se mantienen y
quizás nosotros podríamos intentar
nuevas formas de representar datos